[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
ouais ça va bien je me réveille
complètement ça fait une semaine que
j'étais là et maintenant mesdames
messieurs je voudrais vous montrer des
images absolument incroyable mais qu'est
ce qui m'arrive la mémoire de tram bus
des gages est bloqué dans quoi jacques
faty compliqué salehi certes on l'a
surtout quand organe était marrant toi
t'as vu la gueule que j'ai en plus un
[ __ ] ouais ces trucs là ça se veut
tous tentent un coup de pompe et 5
passes aïe aïe ça a l'air sérieux qu'est
ce qu'on fait faut envoyer la bécane
champex et les mecs vous êtes gentil je
vais quand même pas y passer la nuit un
[ __ ] t'as vu ma gueule je sais pas moi
démerdez vous appelez la fêter bonne
idée
[Musique]
professeur chutes d'audiences
catastrophiques très bien intéressé par
les téléspectateurs
est ce que ça veut dire la vérité c'est
que les gosses ne les aimais pas vous en
foutez les accesseurs vous rendez vous
samedi prochain en attendant vous
retrouvez olivier minne dans quelques
instants régie finale pour le
commentaire des résultats de vos appels
télé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit yves abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus